trouve dans ce livre vous êtes vous allé
encore plus loin vous voulez vous
revenir sur beaucoup de sujets dont on
va parler par exemple sur les effets
secondaires de toute vaccination vous
dites vous dit cet effet nocebo
particulièrement notable au cours des
injections de vaccin ou jusqu'à 8 % des
gens peuvent rapporter après une
injection ne contenant que du sérum
physiologique des douleurs articulaires
des maux de tête des insomnies une
éruption voire de la fièvre l'effet
nocebo commentcamarche pont de
téléspectateurs c'est quoi alors ça
marche très bien c'est d'ailleurs c'est
un point extrêmement important le
l'effet placebo et laisser nocebo yapi
ya beaucoup de choses si vous voulez que
on a je crois que c'est un vrai
scientifique et donc je joue j'essaie de
j'essaie de faire la différence entre ce
qui est de la science et ce qui est ce
que ce que les gens croient être de la
science qui est en réalité une
vision formelle est finie la
connaissance qui est idiote quand on est
un scientifique on sait que la
connaissance évolue tout le temps et
donc je voulais l'effet placebo l'effet
nocebo c'est connu depuis très très
longtemps c'est que
on dirait ça en langage courant que la
manière de données compte autant que ce
que l'on donne jacques goldman
et donc trouver et on pouvait guérir des
maladies qui avaient des visions l'on
sert ses trades c'est très bien connu
pour le sait grâce au duo des non en
fonction de la manière dont ont donné
des pilules dans lequel il y avait du
tac rien du tout et il y avait une
différence considérable d'un métro c'est
à dire que c'est ce qu'il a
il y avait des différences considérables
d'un médecin à l'autre et à peu près 30%
des médecins avaient un effet placebo
c'est à dire que ils ont tiré une
guérison du faussaire que les autres ne
pouvait pas donner accès jusqu'à un
passé récent on pouvait c'est très
différent de la
nôtre science à nous et très a besoin
d'avoir une une vision une
identification de ce qui se passe de le
voir
depuis très peu de temps
depuis très longtemps qu'on peut voir
les modifications du métabolisme du
cerveau et maintenant on voit où se
passent l'effet placebo le plus grand et
plus grands spécialistes mondiaux de
tous les sujets je sais à peu près tous
invités chez moi à donner un séminaire
et vous pouvez voir la localisation de
l'effet placebo c'est la même que celle
des benzodiazépines
c'est à dire que vous calmer les gens et
on voit une modification du métabolisme
cérébral avec l'effet placebo al'inverse
effet nocebo c'était aussi ça fait un
magnifique papier d'art nature bon ça a
été étudié pour faire des ponctions en
faisant les fonctions donc il ya des
gens à qui on dit moi je savais ça
d'expérience si vous leur dit dégoûté
c'est rien du tout c'est finalement
c'est qu'une intramusculaire un peu
profond les gens là ça se passe très
bien si vous leur dites écoutez c'est
extraordinaire les gens qui songent pas
en allemagne il faut en sti locale qui
dure une demi-heure avant de faire la
ponction lombaire ça se passe très mal à
ses sa a été étudié ça c'est à dire que
vous voyez comment ça se passe et dire
qu'il ya eu une activation en corticale
du tronc cérébral qui diffuse dans le
faisceau pyramidale dans le rachis qui
explique l'effet nocebo cette année on a
une visualisation l'effet nocebo et bien
sûr on le sait bien ce que fait la
sophrologie se fait que les gens y croit
ou on n'y croit pas il n'empêche les
gens qui sont soulagés par ça pour de
bon donc le jeu c'est pas toutes les
femmes qui ont fait la couche pas sans
douleur c'est ça c'était ça
l'accouchement sans douleur voilà on
fait
en sorte qu'il part par l'induction
subjective qui est quelque chose qui
fait partie de la médecine et donc c'est
pour ça que pour les vaccins faut faire
très attention ça a été montré sur les
vaccins depuis entre le vaccin qui est
librement consentie et le vaccin qui est
imposé il ya une différence l'effet
nocebo ou non seulement concerner grand
monde et d'ailleurs vous dit deux mots
clefs pau contre le vaccin mix et une
braise question la seule véritable
question qu'on puisse poser c est vous
pour tel vaccin réalisé dans telles
conditions dentelles population à tel
endroit à tel moment chaque question
vous dites c'est une question
scientifique
puisque une question scientifique et
médicale c'est à dire que ça résulte
d'une relation médecin-malade demain
conditions particulières de patients en
particulier dans ce qui vous occupe le
plus maintenant et ce qui est ce qui est
clair c'est que les les sujets âgés et
les obèses ont un risque très
significativement plus important de
faire des formes graves et que donc si
vous en discuter avec eux et
paradoxalement ils ne sont pas très bien
vaccinés dans ce pays c'est à dire le
fait de dire écoutez il faut vacciner
tout le monde avec des choses que les
gens ne comprennent pas on n'arrive plus
à faire comprendre quelque chose qui est
simple cd vous voyez pas que vous vous
avez un risque et que vous vous devez le
faire parce que vous avez à risque wilko
professeurs ou en fait ce que ce que
vous dites là aussi un second il faut
être intelligent cinq ans c'est
difficile
vous avez
vous venez d entre eux l'effet nocebo ce
que vous dites sur le vaccin on comprend
aussi que voilà il est d'ailleurs le
pass vaccinale c'est un peu c'est un peu
fort c'est
beaucoup
concentrez vos souffrances immenses mais
c'est vrai c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai fait parce que ça me prend effet
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que ça tombe
bien vous soyez là aujourd'hui le pass
vaccinale pour un effet c'est vrai que
ça c'est un effet aussi légion il ya
beaucoup de gens qui stresse d'aller se
faire vacciner est-ce que vous pensez
que ça ça peut avoir un rôle aussi sur
les effets sur des effets secondaires
c'est peut-être psychologique aussi nous
s'il vous plaît si longtemps mais je
vais vous dire quelque chose qui
n'existait pas parce qu'on n'avait pas
assez de remiremont j'ai écrit ce livre
d'accord l'interprétation des faits
aussi bien du vaccin que de la maladie
dépend de l'opinion que vous en avez par
exemple actuellement quand on vous dit à
tant de personnes qui sont mortes avec
au micro mais aura été le virus circule
tellement qu'il ya une quantité de gens
qui sont morts de toutes autres choses
qui sont en réanimation pour toute autre
raison mais comme on fait des
prélèvements au micron pour tout le
monde de trouver au biberon d'eau dans
ce qui veut dire que la relation de
cause à effet qui est également un
élément essentiel est difficile c'est
souvent en multi factorielle les côtes
eh bien elle ne va pas être la même
selon que vous pensez que on est face à
une pandémie qui tue tout le monde ou
que vous pensez que c'est jamais que
comme d'habitude un virus qui circule
pour les vaccins c'est la même chose
vous aviez vu la direction de la
réflexion de la directrice de l'année
c'est mai puis il ya un grand débat
actuellement autour de la collection en
europe des effets secondaires des
vaccins dans laquelle les gens disent
écoutez j'ai eu un vaccin et g ou tel
événement est donc d sûr naturellement
tout le monde fait un lien du fait de ce
qu'on appelle la temporalité c'est à
dire le fait qu' il s'est passé sept
jours obligeant monde entre l'un et
l'autre mais l'interprétation de ça et
vous savez qu'elle a dit trois fois rien
que sur le vaccin qu'on vide que ce
qu'on avait sur toutes les déclarations
de tous les médicaments c'est très
intéressant face dans le professeur oui
mais comment comment on interprète ce
lien donc il ya ceux qui disent non pas
que ça y est pour rien circulez ya rien
à voir et à ce lieu qui disent non à
100% qu'ils sont liés ça a été sûrement
entre les deux ben maintenant comment on
fait pour les myocardite je vous
rappelle que simplement quand on a eu
les premières autopsies de locarn id
qu'on a dit non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
les vaccins qui censure mais envers dit
jusque là on dit non mais il ya des
myocarde y avoir de démontrer et l'
inverse ça a été vrai moi je vous
rappelle que
si on est dans une situation il ya eu
une situation aussi critique vis-à-vis
des vaccins c'est parce que kouchner a
décidé qu'il fallait arrêter la
vaccination dans les écoles parce que
j'avais dit qu'il y avait un lien entre
la sclérose en plaques est là pour
l'hépatite b qui n'a jamais existé crs
qui factuellement statistiquement m'a
jamais jamais existé
nathalie alors moi j'ai une question
parce que j'ai mon père qui s'est
vacciner et jean-pierre en même temps
que jean alors c'est la femme de jean
pierre pernaut voilà monsieur pernaut et
mon père huit jours après a eu un zona
et jean-pierre malheureusement là depuis
janvier ça va être un super scoop pour
vous mais non ma fait qu'à la mini a
baissé depuis qu'il a eu ce vaccin donc
et quand je suis à l'hôpital et que je
dis aux médecins c'est quand même
bizarre parce qu'on ne trouve pas on
fait tous les examens possibles sur
jean-pierre pour trouver d'où ça vient
c'est mimi avc on ne le trouve pas et à
l'hôpital jeux d'écouté depuis café ce
vaccin oui jours après il a fait ça est
ce qu'il ya un rapport et eu tout de
suite il dit non non non non non surtout
pas jeudi mais il faudrait le dire le
comme pour mon père le zona il faudrait
le dire et aussi une autre chose c'est
que le jour où je me suis fait vacciner
le lendemain
le jericho vide ma fille le joie s'est
fait vacciner le lendemain la hulpe
loaded
un truc non mais incroyable moi je suis
pour les vaccins parce que j'ai fait mes
trois vaccins je suis pas contre un je
fais mes trois vaccins jean-pierre été
pour les vaccins aussi voila voila on
suit comme les petits moutons mais on
fait les vaccins mais pour continuer à
vivre mais là je trouve et des
infirmières aussi que j'ai rencontrés
quand je leur ai expliqué santiago c'est
marrant parce que nous quand on a fait
notre troisième dose aussi le lendemain
en alcôve id est la seule infirmière cas
pas eu sa troisième dose elle elle n'a
pas elle n'a pas eu un creux vide donc
là mon fils je veux voir parce que
aujourd'hui il faisait sa troisième dose
tom et ça m'inquiète un peu tous ces
choses d'abord il ya des choses pour
lequel il faut il faut il faut du temps
d'abord il faut que les passions aux
tombes parce que là toute manière entre
ceux qui n'y est une chose ceux qui ni
l'autre et finit par avoir des
difficultés
donc il faut un peu de temps pour
analyser ça voyez regarder pour le
lisseur la sclérose en plaques et de
l'hépatite b en france parce que jamais
été qu'une histoire française cette
histoire il a fallu quelques années pour
qu'on revienne dessus moi c'est une
histoire qui me qui me touche
particulièrement à coeur parce que peu
de temps après j'étais chargé de mission
au ministère j'ai essayé de faire une
une réunion internationale est conseillé
au ministre fait une réunion
internationale pour remettre les choses
à part pour des lecteurs peut pas avoir
juste des scléroses en plaques comme en
france avec des 25 tout le monde n'a pas
de sens et immédiatement tous les gens
qui avaient été recrutés par le ministre
précédent avait expliqué jean françois
mattei que je faisais partie du lot est
ce qu'il est et ce alors que je pense
qu'on dirait plutôt le monde irait plus
loin vers sa folie des faits mais c'est
vrai c'est fou c'est à dire on n'a pas
le droit de réfléchir on est dans un
camp ou dans un autre camp et donc c'est
tout notre monde sait ce que je sais
bien sûr c'est ce que vous dites ici on
est dans un camp ou dans l'autre le
professeur ou d'os que vous venez bien
voulait dire on n'a pas encore assez de
recul nécessaire comme vous avez parlé
des vaccins avec la sclérose en plaques
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas ça on a su
après qu'il y avait rien à voir entre ce
que disaient les chiffres kouchner et la
sclérose en plaques mais on va devoir
attendre de nombreuses années avant de
savoir mine de rien il ya des choses
qu'on mettra longtemps à prendre il y en
a d'autres qui sont il ya des événements
rares ce qu'on arrive bien à repérer
c'est quand des événements rares sont
plus fréquents après la vaccination
parce que comme ils sont rares et il
attire l'attention place tels cas même
qu'il y avait beaucoup qu'ils soient
passés
à la trappe
c'était le cas avec les thrombose
vasculaire chez les femmes jeunes moi je
verrais très tôt averti pour astrazeneca
ne fait pas de vaccin je vais faire vous
le savez vous le saviez très vite faut
s'allier ça me protège a replacé les
syndicats d'abord parce que on avait eu
un cas dans l'hôpital après j'ai dit
j'ai été accusé de faire une campagne
contre la vaccination chez les soignants
j'ai rien fait du tout c'est les
soignants on savait très bien qu'il y
avait un d'entre eux qui avait fait un
accident dès que vous dites un truc où
vous accuse maintenant oui oui mais
j'avais dit si on mord quelqu'un si on
mord un chien dans la timone c'est pas
moi on tournait presque l'avancé petit à
petit on est presque là donc il y a des
moments où les choses sont inaudibles
mais ça par exemple les myocardite ce
n'est pas non plus très très fréquent
quand on voit des myocardite c'est des
choses qu'on analyse par exemple il y
avait quelque chose qui est assez
troublant c'était au moment de l'épisode
de la chana le vaccin h1n1 donné alors
qu'on a dit on attendait tous qu'ils
donnent des paralysies qui s'appelle les
syndromes de guillain-barré ont donné ce
qu'on appelle les narcolepsie et les
gens qui s'en donnent au milieu de la
journée comme ça et c'est une maladie
qui est tellement
c'est un finlandais qui a ré cac a
rapporté ça que tout de suite on a dit
non mais c'est vrai il ya quelque chose
avec la narcolepsie parce qu'il y en a
dix fois plus que ce qu'on en voit
d'habitude quoi donc les événements
rares de cette nature là on les voit
mais les accidents vasculaires cérébraux
ou jaune a fait les choses qui sont
fréquentes il faut faire les tests
statistiques avant des groupes de
comparaison pour pouvoir comprendre
parce que là ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver d'où ça vient ils ont envoyé un
baiser and mail tous les examens
inimaginable il trouve que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de ces
situations auxquelles on ne trouve pas
une explication qui est la piscine et
c'est pas une séance finie la signature
quand vous entendez des gens dire que le
variant au micro on peut sauver le monde
c'est quoi vous en rigoler
je suis pas trop ce que ça veut dire
mais le variant au micron lui-même il et
il donne plusieurs leçons très
intéressante que j'essaie d'expliquer le
tous les vaccins les vaccins moléculaire
ont été basées sur
m de l'adn bla et rennes où la reine et
l'adn parce que les vaccins ya plein de
diriger contre la spike et la spa il
comporte plusieurs parties il ya une
partie qui permet de s'attacher aux
cellules et il ya une partie dont on
soupçonne nous qu'elle fait puis c'est
des soupçons qui garnissent qu'elle fait
des anticorps facilitant et d'ailleurs
c'est un papier très très jolie qui
vient de sortir chez les obèses
américain a beaucoup de compris dans
l'armée dont qu'ils ont compris ils ont
comparé dans l'armée les obèses donne au
bez et les obèses ceinture font des
formes peu graves ils portent le virus
plus longtemps ils font quelque chose
qu'on ait remarqué mais je n'ai pas été
assez malin pour insister dessus un peu
plus d'un an quand on a commencé à faire
des sérologies regarder les anticorps
contre la spike c'est que les gens qui
sont les plus malades sont ceux qui ont
le plus anti corps et c'est très étrange
parce que les gens au zinc ou
d'anticorps ils ont encore le virus qui
veut dire que les élans du coeur sont
pas neutralisant d'accord au début il y
avait on était troublé parce qu'il y
avait une telle explosion d'anticorps
dans tous les sens y compris d'anticorps
contre soi
une partie expliquant des noms des
accidents vasculaires les thromboses et
c'est que on me dit tiens il essaie des
vaccins kit cdc des anticorps contre le
virus mais qui sont inutiles on pensait
pas le concept d'anticorps facilitant
qui existe pourtant d'autres maladies en
particulier qu'il très très connu pour
la dengue était quelque chose on n'a pas
envisagé à cette époque là que les
anticorps pouvait au contraire aggraver
la maladie et non pas la guérir la
contrôler et c'est quelque chose qu'on
est en train de voir nous et qu'on ait
le que d'autres voix on est très embêté
qu'ils aient publié salon nous alors
dans l'eee vous revenez aussi sur un
autre combat un autre de vos combats
depuis deux ans et le traitement
médiatique fait autour du covin et dans
la science en général vous trouvez que
le pouvoir des médias peut-être
dangereux mais nous sommes au début
d'une époque où l'information sont
hiérarchie le courrier des lecteurs les
réseaux sociaux vont pouvoir redéfinir
parfois même sans aucun substrat
réaliste la médecine et ses dangers ça
vous a porté préjudice tout ce qui s'est
dit sur les réseaux sociaux sur cette
maladie qui on a tout entendu ou pas du
tout normand refuge vraiment non mais
c'est pas là que ça vous dit que il ya
trop de personnes qui n'y connaissent
rien te parle partout en fait c'est ça
je ne sais pas si c'est ça que je pense
ce que je pense et vous voulez y est je
crois que je donne deux dans l'exemple
que que certains connaissent peut-être
de ce restaurant anglais qui n'existait
pas qu'il est devenu premier surpris pas
de vision serait pas non non écouter des
gens ils seront bien les gens qui
faisaient vous savez bien que c'est
truqué la popularité vous parliez des
gens qui cliquent quitté clic président
on a un exemple
scc les bandits donc la popularité s'est
enfin c'est de l'argent donc ses débuts
signature et donc il y avait des gens
qui faisait ça les cliques et clips pour
les tripes à deux buts pour pour les
restaurants trip advisor en angleterre
ces farceurs un moment à quatre ils ont
dit on va faire un coup vont inventer un
restaurant qui n'existaient pas ils ont
bien un téléphone en disant on ne peut
manger que par réservation quand on
faisait des réservations il y avait un
répondeur qui disait écouter on n'a pas
de place et cliquer et recliquer qu'il
est au fur et à mesure la notoriété
étant ce qu'elle est parce que ça ça
revient vraiment vraiment vraiment sur
le le
le suivisme c'est que tout le monde
trouvait ce restaurant extraordinaire
pour lui paraître numéro un à l'ombre de
tous les restaurants et à la fin ils ont
montré que c'était une farce ils ont bon
je sais pas trop dans leur jardin et
d'en photographier en disant voilà ce
que c'est comment l'information peut
devenir voyez c'est c'est extraordinaire
moi j'ai inventé le chroniqueur qui
n'existe pas
alors oui c'est extraordinaire ce que
vous dites parce que ça me rejoint ça
rejoint l'idée de ce que vous venez dans
le livre ça rejoint si on fait un petit
enfant il ya un team point garder ça qui
s'appelle arche qui est un des plus
grands psychologique siècle qui avait
fait cette expérience qui est la même
que celle que goggles données de goggles
disait si vous répétez suffisamment avec
suffisamment suffisamment longtemps un
public qui est choisie qu'un rond et
d'un quart et il finit par penser que
c'est un carré et arch l'a prouvé ça
c'est à dire que l'art qui il faisait ce
qui m'était une équipe de dix personnes
y en avait neuf qui étaient ses copains
à qui il faisait répondre ce qu'ils
voulaient et le 10e qui l'interrogeaient
pour lui demander ce qu'il voyait et lui
montrer un trait d'accord il y avait les
9 qui disait voilà ça c'est plus petit
que ça les 9 10 et ça et lui qui voyait
que le traiterait plus long il disait si
on avait un tiers qui disait comme la
majorité oui et c'est le plus petit à
ces fonds et parce que voyez le cerveau
en parlerait pas influencer être
professeur à rouge vous le dis je vois
la génération égal avec vous ce pas
vraiment non mais vraiment jolie sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est un bonheur on voit
la merci en tout cas vraiment on va
encore parler parce qu'on vous êtes
encore là on vous bougez pas mais c'est
vrai que je vous dis voilà parce que là
les gens me disent c'est formidable le
professeur a ou et formidable ce soir
oui moi j'aimerais bonsoir on fait ça je
suis je suis ravi de vous avoir en face
de moi j'aimerais ça vous êtes avec ma
photo rang
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dubourg
sorte et je sais que vous en avez
énormément contrairement à d'autres
cette
profession est pardon pardon c'est vrai
plus important vous pouvez aujourd'hui
nous dira si il est normal qu'on pousse
les gens à vacciner les enfants est-ce
que vous pouvez nous assuré aujourd'hui
que si on vaccine aux enfants ils ne
risquent rien de ce vaccin est ce qu'il
est logique de pousser les parents
vacciner
il a déjà répondu là dessus monsieur
raoult et ils l'ont maintes et maintes
fois dans cette émission pour y répondre
une fois de plus un professeur mais
encore une fois moi je je je crois que
les vaccins doivent servir à quelque
chose
d'accord donc si on prend ça comprend à
peu près tout ce que je veux dire c'est
à dire que pour servir les vaccins
peuvent avoir plusieurs
fonctions la première c'est de vous
protéger
théoriquement les vaccins jusqu'à
maintenant en à vous vous allez voir on
vit une grande mutation dans les vaccins
parce qu'au début ce vaccin était fait
pour nous empêcher d'être infectés ça
maintenant on sait qu'il nous empêche
pas du tout affecté plus on vaccine puis
c'est la france est en train de devenir
le numéro 1 au numéro 1 on était numéro
un européen attend d'être numéro un
mondial et reste juste les états unis à
battre ces navettes médaille d'or
c'est sain c'est un premier point c'est
à dire que ça ne va pas arrêter
l'épidémie camp et ça ne va pas arrêter
les infections je crois qu'à peu près
tout le monde est d'accord vous devrait
être d'accord alors il sera temps de
regarder on est d'accord suffit de
regarder les chiens sur après essayant
d'y écouter donc ça ça empêche pas
l'infection ni la circulation mais
s'attache pas non plus d'être malades
donc c'est un premier vaccin qu'on a qui
n'empêche pas dont l'objectif n'est pas
d'empêcher d'être malade alors redit ben
non mais attendez ça empêche les formes
graves ce qui est possible
ce qui sur le au micro on va être
difficile à prouver parce que la maladie
elle-même est très bénigne et encore une
fois que ce soit maintenant ou avant les
seuls qui font des formes graves sont
les gens qui ont plus de 65 ans les
obèses et quelques personnes qui ont des
anomalies rarissime en plus de ça donc
après vous pensez ce que vous voulez moi
je pense que si on pense à l'utiliser d
en soi ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
ait pas autre chose que l'été était en
soi un l'utile usage par les politiques
de mesures sanitaires à 9 ça peut ne pas
servir que en soit l'objectif avoué j'en
sais rien je
vais vous donner un autre exemple en
tirer les conséquences at il donné un
eagle entre exhorte à saint marc où il
va il va vous donner un exemple d'après
vous réfléchirez cheyrou pour savoir si
m
[Rires]
j'aime bien répondre en faisant un côté
bien sûr est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
une raison médicale
a empêché la cigarette électronique
vous revenez demain
donc cette source avant
ces deux là je sais c'est de la gestion
sarr du comportement vous allez dire on
vous oblige avant un comportement et ce
comportement on le fait au nom de
quelque chose qui n'a pas de base
scientifique médical n'ont pas besoin de
vacciner ses enfants pour être des
raccourcis professeur house parlez vous
alors vous raconter aussi paul
d'histoire sur vous on en sait un peu
plus sur vous grâce aux nous parle aussi
de la violence de la politique vous
dites j'ai été candidat puis élu à la
présidence de mon université en 94
j'avais été sidéré par les rumeurs qui
avaient circulé à l'époque votre égard
certains syndicats ces et courir le
bruit que jeune je faisais partie du
groupe d'extrême droite le but d' de
faire cet âge là j'étais plutôt
anarchiste voilà vous aviez la même
coiffure
jean capillairement jamais
notre vous étiez alcoolique notre que je
battais ma femme et d'autres enfin que
je cassais les portes plutôt que
d'ouvrir et c'est vrai qu'on sent que
l'analogie avec avec ce qui se passe
maintenant on vous trouve on essaie
toujours de vous chercher voilà sûr que
sur plein de sujets et vous avez vu déjà
à l'époque vous étiez candidat à la
présidence donc est même élu d'ailleurs
le président de votre université voyez
déjà la violence ce qu'on vous dit dans
lyon oui oui il ya une violence
politique et payer une violence payer
que m'excuser ça qui est celle de la
notoriété je pensais
des raisons multiples mais que qui sont
d'une actualité que vous saisirez je
pensais à chela
et
cette femme a vécu pendant vingt ans le
fait qu'on disait qu'en réalité c'était
un transsexuel ex tu es un homme la
malheureuse a filmé son accouchement
pour montrer ça à son fils son fils est
devenu malade de sa propre notoriété est
jaloux de sa forte notoriété écrit un
livre et puis partit comme vous savez et
donc le le le l'horreur de la notoriété
ou la jalousie que suscite une autorité
comme ça d'une gamine qui à 17 ans passe
sur tous les trucs et les premières et
arabes c'est quelque chose qui est inouï
de la jalousie et l'envi sait capable de
susciter des mouvements de haine qui
sont étonnants mois il se trouve que la
première fois que j'ai vécu ça de plein
front s'était effectivement quand
j'étais candidat à lui verser ce champ
tandis les trucs là réellement je tombe
des nues donc après j'ai bien compris on
le voit d'ailleurs à chaque élection
présidentielle ce que l'on est capable
de subir quand on monte dans l'arbre
saihi varin
donc il faut vous réveiller quand on
grimpe à là on a intérêt à voir le
volet c'est peut-être que c'est je sais
rien peut-être que dans des fonctions de
cette nature là peut-être que c'est
utile moi je suis comme vous le savez je
suis un grand amateur de nietzsche donc
je pense que le conflit est générateur
d'intelligence dont vous m'en fous ça
veut dire que vous êtes obligés d'être
intelligent quand vous êtes
conflictuelle donc on peut pas si vous
voulez pas si vous n'êtes pas
intelligent vous êtes un terrain
d'accord elle tout le monde comme ça
personne ne vous embête ensuite lorsque
vous pensez au lido de l'ine de la tête
comme pour être en étant d'accord et
puis tout va bien donc si vous décidez
de ne pas être d'accord aussi votre
nature n'est pas d'accord il faut bien
se rendre compte que quand dès qu'on
sort un peu de troupeau on prend des
coups c'est comme ça c'est vraiment et
c'est normal mais vous mais c'est vrai
que professeur vous parliez de la
notoriété un instant pour regretter
d'avoir été autant médiatisé où vous
regrettez pas du tout
franchement je m'en fous parce que je me
rends pas compte vraiment parce que vous
êtes une énorme star c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je vous dis professeur
house vous faites partie franchement des
trois quatre personnalités françaises
elle est connue et populaire on va pas
se sentir aujourd'hui c'est vrai
aujourd'hui vous avez menti vous savez
je ne regarde pas la télévision je le
lis pas les journaux allemands excuses
j'écoute pas la radio
france il faudra compter je devais
raconter tout ce que vous voulez savoir
de temps en temps si vous voulez ça
prend ça prend de temps en temps une
telle ampleur que 6 accor yade et il ya
des politiques qui ne m'aiment pas il
utilise des fausses informations pour
m'ennuyer alors comment voix mais c'est
pas de maintenant on m'envoie des la g3
mission ministérielle à la fois sur l'a1
a qui disent qu'on a fait des
traitements antituberculeux magique
puisque ce qu'on va pas fait des chèques
des choses qui sont écrites dans les
livres il y en a qui disent que il faut
vérifier notre gouvernance c'est sûr que
nous on vit à côté de da chu qui à 1,2
milliard de dettes n'a qui n'a jamais
réussi à boucler son budget une année
depuis les décennies d'accord et nous on
n'a aucune dette on a toujours boucler
notre budget c'est avec 2 % des forces
du chu l'on produit 20 2% de sa
recherche donc c'est normal qu'on nous
demande à nous le problème de la
gouvernance et ses fins pour vous imiter
mais dans un monde intelligent on imite
ce qui marche pour pour dire écoutez
bien sûr mais nous votre scène pour
savoir comment ça marche est-ce que doux
comme ça marche ça fait tâche à côté des
autres qui savent pas le faire parce
qu'ils ont un système où on vous balance
et cheap quand ils sortent d'un cabinet
on les balance là parce qu'on s'est pas
coupé il ya de la jalousie il ya
énormément de nouveaux professeurs cc
oui mais encore une fois c'est la nature
ça qu'est ce que vous voulez faire c'est
comme ça
c'est compliqué oui ou non il ya une
stratégie pour lutter contre le coc vite
qu'on n'a jamais testé depuis le début
de la pandémie c'est de ne rien faire
c'est à dire pas de masse pas de
restriction pas de mon fils qui vont
faire en angleterre voilà emmanuel
macron au début de la pandémie je crois
qu'il avait dit qu'il n'avait rien fait
il y aurait eu quatre cent mille morts
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
non mais c'est tout simplement une
question de la chaussée
non mais bon je vous parle je
sais pas qui c'est qui dit ça avec ses
modèles si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
a pris dit quelque chose qui soit vrai
moi dans mon métier sait jamais et puis
c'est très intéressant il vient de
sortir un papier dans nature sur le
l'épidémie dans les différents
continents alors bien sûr les plus
mauvais c'est l'amérique et nous
assurons puce tu essaies de vos clients
le plus de cas et les meilleurs ceux qui
ont eu le moins de casse et l'afrique
très très peur j'ai eu très très peur
conclusion des gens de là
les afriques et en plus l'habitude des
épidémies ça fait un mois que je pense
que c'est beaucoup la médecine
communautaire s'occupe des malades 1h10
par rester à la maison je vais pas
pouvoir parler de libre ils vont les
voir il est trés terrebonne quelque
chose parfois des infusions pour lui
expliquer ce qu'il faisait ce qui
donnait pas beaucoup de liens avec
l'afrique mais ce qui est la conclusion
dans nature c'est de l'afrique devrait
se préparer à préparer elle même ses
vaccins marco
voyez donc il n'est pas venu à l'idée
une seconde de dire mais attendez
qu'est-ce qu'ils font que ça fait mieux
que nous c'est on sait nous ce qu'il
faut faire on va pas changer la vie
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et il devrait
faire comme nous pour être moderne
centralisée et coxyde professeur didier
raoult chronique pour une humanité en
quête de repères ce cousin un dernier
mot à dire c'est chez michel lafon très
très bon sens inné du professeur ou
vraiment gillard était magnifique
magnifique on avait plein de choses
fantastiques et est ce que ce que vous
avez une dernière chose à dire sur ce
livret ou à nos téléspectateurs soit non
c'est pour ça que je m'excuse je ne veux
pas je ne veux pas dire que je je je
méprise les gens qui ont une opinion
sûrement simplement moi mon objectif est
à pour ça que je suis un peu en
discordance et vous voulez avec une
partie du monde qui m'envient rhône sont
pas des objectifs à court terme qui ne
m'intéresse pas encore et moi pour mon
premier livre où j'ai essayé de parler
des maladies infectieuses nouvelle qu'on
appelait les maladies émergentes chez
publie chez que c'est parce qu'ils
avaient été refusés partout ailleurs et
j'ai dû changer le titre pour mater
nouvelles maladies infectieuses parce
que personne ne savait ce que c'était
une maladie émergente d'accord et donc
on parle des années 90 et moi ce qui
m'importe c'est de pouvoir le reprendre
vous pouvez l'acheter d'occasions que
sais-je et ne pas avoir honte d'un seul
des mots que j'ai écrit l'époque c'est
ça qui m'intéresse c'est sa vis-à-vis de
moi-même je veux d'accord avec moi-même
et dire écoute et sur les choses ont
changé bien sûr les choses nouvelles qui
sont apparus qu'on ne connaissait pas
mais tu n'as pas écrit de bêtises